- Oh my gosh, you're funny!
So, I'm leading with that.
Have you met Jay before?
- No, I'm like sandwiched,
in between like two
American icons right now.
- I love that I'm somehow
in the same sentence as him,
thank you.
- Is that the old Mr. Beef restaurant?
- It is.
- That's my favorite. My
picture is on the wall.
- Yes. Your picture is on the wall.
- That is the most guy-centric restaurant.
There's not a vegetable
in a hundred miles.
- [Ayo] No, no.
- It's just like a sausage rolled
Italian beef in a roll.
They dip the whole thing
in some kind of grease.
Fantastic!
(audience laughs)
- My mouth just watered
and I'm not a dude.
I think it sounds awesome.
I heard that you wanted
to ask Jay something.
- Well, I mean,
it's sort of, we could
discuss it, you know.
I don't know if there's
like an overt question.
- Oh, okay.
- I did, I got my license for the show.
I'm from the East Coast and so I-
- Where did you grow up?
- I grew up in Boston.
- Oh! I'm in Boston! Where in Boston?
- I'm from Dorchester.
- Are you a double-decker
or a triple-decker?
- Triple-decker.
- Ooh, ooh!
- [Kelly-] Alright, alright, alright.
- Oh, I'm sorry. Triple-decker, yeah.
Now, those are all the cool houses.
- [Ayo] Yeah.
- So you didn't drive there?
- I didn't drive there.
I just took the T and
then I went to school
in New York, and I was like,
"I'm gonna take the train forever.
I'm gonna live forever".
And then I moved out here, and I was like,
"What are we doing? We're driving?"
- See, that's my nightmare:
taking the train forever.
- An adult skill that I needed to have?
- Do you find...do you like it?
Are you comfortable doing it or no?
- When you drive...
- Yeah, I like driving.
It's me imagining driving,
No, I like it.
I like putting on a song,
I've never driven before.
- [Kelly] Yeah! A playlist!
- I like putting like
a playlist, you know,
kinda like getting in a zone.
- You'll get to know
this is your alone time.
- Yes.
- I like alone time.
- Yeah, don't get in
a zone. Drive the car.
(hosts and audience laugh)
- Yeah, don't go in a zone.
- Okay. So you started out
learning comedy in Boston,
like Jay, right?
- Yeah.
- What was that like?
- It was a lot of open mic nights
and my friends and I, we
were kind of interested.
I feel like we got
interested pretty young.
And so it was like, us in high school,
like a bunch of weirdos who
did improv and were like
"We could try this stand up thing".
(audience coos)
- [Ayo] Yes.
- [Kelly] I think that's so cool.
- So that very strange person
going to like, an open mic night in Boston
where it's like, all
these, you know, like,
dudes, especially.
- Grown people.
- Who are like, "Ugh! Let
me tell you about my wife".
And I'm like-
(audience laughs)
- But Boston's a great comedy town
cause it's such a quirky, odd place.
- [Ayo] Yeah.
- I love Boston.
It's one of my favorite touring stops.
- Oh!
- Here's a, I'm gonna give
you a Boston compliment.
(Jay fumbles for words)
I'll try to use different words.
(Ayo chuckles)
Guy says to me, "Hey, my friend!"
This stranger,
"My friend met you in California.
He said, You're not an (muted)".
- Yep.
- I went, "Oh, well thanks."
The guy goes, "No, really!"
I go, "Well, thank you very much, sir.
I appreciate that".
And that, I mean, that's
a compliment in Boston!
- When the show came out,
my parents came to the
premiere, and my dad was like,
"You know, I think I'll
actually watch this one".
And I was like, "Oh! Thanks dad".
An he was like, "No,
no! Really! I mean it!"
- Yeah! Exactly!
- "Really! I'm gonna watch it!"
And he did.
- And it's very suspicious in Boston,
"What are you, in California now?
You got a gardener out there?
Or you do your own gardening?"
I do my own garden.
"Oh, okay."
(audience laughs)
- They're like sizing you.
- You can't be putting on those airs.
- You know, triple-decker accredited all.
That's a whole other level.
- Well, I wanna say congrats on The Bear.
I mean, so much success.
For those of you who haven't seen it,
tell everybody what is it about.
- It is about a restaurant in Chicago.
It's an Italian beef restaurant
and just the people who work there,
when they get along, when
they don't, and yeah.
Just trying to make it like a legit place.
- Yeah. It's amazing. It did so well.
Everybody was talking about it all summer.
- Oh yeah. It's a lot of fun.
And it's a real place.
- Whenever I'm in Chicago, I go there-
- Your picture. I'm, like,
I've looked at your picture
while we were filming.
It's on the wall.
- I'm like 19 in that picture. Yeah.
And it looks all, it's all cleaned up.
Oh, there it is! There you go, Mr. Beef!
That's hilarious.
- I love the name of this place. Right?
(audience laughs)
You're walking around.
I'm a little hungry. Mr. Beef!
- You know you're not
getting a veggie burger
when you go in.
- Mr. Beef. Every
vegetarian is going in, yes.
- It's like stepping in
a time capsule there too.
It's like, they're Cash
Only still I think.
It's like, everybody who works there
has worked there for forever.
They're like all such a family.
- I Love those kind of places.
- Yeah. It's really cool.
- Well, this is a good segway.
We will all be doing some
cooking in our next segment.
You look scared.
- I got a heads up about the recipe.
I got a heads up.
- Okay. The Bear is streaming now on Hulu.
You've got to watch it.